[Music]
my name
is cara zorel 24 years ago my planet was
in peril
my cousin carl was sent to a planet
called earth
you may know his story but you don't
know mine
on earth you will do extraordinary
things until now
you must go i love you carl
oh sorry sorry i'm calling about the
correspondence dinner i need
to make sure ms grant doesn't end up
next to bill o'reilly again
hey um i was wondering if maybe you want
to i don't know go see a movie tonight
i can't i'm sorry i have a date
day fun dating is fun
she's here how do you do that the only
reason i bought this building was
because it had a private elevator that
way i don't have to get soaked in cheap
cologne every morning getting to my
office find out who used it have them
reprimanded or bathed
i don't care which here's your latte hot
oh that'll be new and different
hello i've seen this picture you're
going to pull it sir
yeah only because it was the first real
shot of a little secret he actually
posed for that guess she likes me
oh my god you're jimmy olsen
photographer from the daily planet james
olson
i never got your name gosh
cara wow
[Music]
i have a conference in geneva and i need
to be on a plane in two hours i have a
blind date and a half an hour and i need
you to help me pick out what to wear why
do you do this to me
cause i'm your sister and you love me i
feel like i'm not living up to my
potential
i just fetched layouts and coffee you
always wanted to be normal this is what
normal looks like
i'm not normal i can lift a bus stop a
bullet alex i can fly
at least i think i can why 237 bound for
geneva
is circling the city after an engine
failure did he say geneva
[Music]
oh come on
who is the mystery flying woman who
saved the plane
oh my god you exposed yourself
you're out there now cara everyone will
know about you and you
can't take that back i don't want to
media magnet cat grant of national
city's new female hero
supergirl we can't name her that we
didn't shouldn't you be called super
woman what do you think is so bad about
girl
i'm a girl and your boss
and powerful and rich
and hot and smart so if you perceive
supergirl as anything less than
excellent
isn't the real problem you
tara i'm going to tell you something
about me that for most of my life i've
run from it
but last night i embraced who i am and i
don't want to stop
oh my god you're a lesbian oh cara
that's why you're not into me this is
this is this is great news
jay i'm her the woman who saved the
plane
okay right carl what are you doing
hey cara
you're her yep
i'm not flying around saving people in
this thing where's my cape
capes are lame you tell your cousin i
said so actually never never do that
so to be a superhero you need a crime
there's a car chase on the 112 freeway i
could do a car shake
a cape aids with aerodynamics i should
have thought of that
suspects are armed and dangerous you uh
you sure you're bulletproof
hope so
all right the new cape is made from
structured polymer composite it's much
sturdier than
and uh this one has the s
for super just like your cousin it's not
an s
it's my family's coat of arms the house
of l
[Music]
welcome to the department of extranormal
operations
the deo monitors and protects earth from
extraterrestrial presence
these beings some of them are powers
from your darkest nightmares
i can help you stop them i don't trust
aliens you want to help
go back to getting someone's coffee
cara it's me i know what you're thinking
but the world needs you to fly
and so do i
so what do we do now first things first
you need to change this
i didn't travel 2 000 light years just
to be an assistant
people of this city will die
you have to let me stop it make sure you
right
win
my cousin wanted me to do this why
didn't he just tell me
because he wanted you to choose it for
yourself
same way he did here from him
it's the blanket he was wrapped in when
he was a baby apparently
this cape won't tread thank you now
don't you have a city to protect you
know up up and away
[Applause]
be